peace welcome to the dean show i'm into
your host
thank you for tuning in my next guest
sheikh asim bill look man el hakeem
graduated from the prestigious
um el corado university in mecca he's
been the local imam for the past 22
years in juddah where the sheikh
delivers weekly friday sermons and
lectures on various islamic sciences
sheikh asam hakeem also participates
regularly both on radio and television
programs to spread the authentic
teachings of the quran and the sunnah
he's
here with us on the dean's show today
for having me with a simple correction
when you said since 22 years
this brought so many good memories
uh unfortunately
it's 35 years now
so
so it shows the total of time on us
you got to up the update the bio there
i should that should yeah
so 35 years you have a lot of experience
you're also the host of one of the most
popular q and a sessions out there
helping people
uh and educate them
uh on some of the basic fundamentals of
the dean
and i just can't uh forget uh the first
time i think we met was in um
for uh the peace tv
and mumbai do you remember that
yeah sure sure i do
yeah that was the last one wasn't it
no it wasn't no
in 2014 in dubai
in the peace conference as well we met
earlier in 2009 i think we're 10 in uh
mumbai for peace conference but then
2014 in dubai the last peace conference
there
tell me i cannot uh recollect which
lecture with this was you know when you
meet someone or you listen to something
from them and then it sticks in your
mind there's
every time i associate you with this one
lecture
and it hits home and you talk about if
you can just remind me
it's a lecture where you're talking
about
something about how everybody
has someone closest to them
that
somehow they're being tested through
like someone who's appointed just like
and then you related to the prophet saw
some that do you remember the specific
lecture you were talking about you've
given so many yeah i'm too old to to
remember eddie come on i am not as young
as you i can barely remember what i had
for lunch yesterday was it through a
tube or was it normal food i'm too
senile but the way the way you put it
together that you know i'm not doing it
justice but something along the lines
that there'll be an enemy closest to you
you can be on the path of doing
righteousness of conveying the message
or what not and it could be your closest
family members somebody some means it's
always it's just inevitable
this is a known fact each and every one
of us is tested
on in this life and this test
varies some of us are tested with wealth
so billionaires shouldn't be happy
because this is a test and seldomly
you'll find someone who passes this test
others are tested by poverty
and
those who are sick of being poor again
this is a test so health is a test uh
sickness is a test power is a test being
the underdog is a test
this is what life is all about allah
stated
the one who created
death and life
liable to test you
so this is a test now
if it is an easy test it wouldn't be a
test so someone says sheikh
allah has given me
abusive parents they're so rude and
they're so disconsiderate and they're so
bad when they deal with us their
children
so
how can i be steadfast i'm trying my
level best but i'm not succeeding
if allah gave you a mother who's a
sweetheart
and a father that is
providing for you buying your cars and
giving you money unconditionally and not
ever asking you to carry a bag of
groceries with him
and then you come and say alhamdulillah
i'm beautiful where is your test
the test is when you are tested
so
the closer a person to you is
the harder the betrayal is the harder
the test is
so always be
on your guard
never enslave yourself
to wealth
never enslave yourself
to spouses
or children or close friends
be a slave of allah azzawajal love
everybody
to the best of your ability be
considerate be compassionate but always
never let your guard down because you
never know when the test is going to
come
subhanallah that's so true
so that would answer the question
for the atheist who says now if there's
a god then why is there so much evil in
the world you kind of answered it
because this life is a test
well for atheists
we
feel sorry for them
and
they have our condolences
because they
unfortunately have missed the whole
thing
and
they know it deep inside so we don't
usually go out of our way to convince
them there's no need to
yeah if you just tell me
how can this be created
i'm fine with that
allah says in the quran
have they been created
via vacuum of out of nothing
nothing created them or were they the
creators of themselves
of course vacuum creates nothing
so
definitely they were not created by
nothing
if you were to bring a chunk of metals
and put it in your room and lock your
room for a thousand year or a a hundred
thousand years it would not come out to
be a porsche 911s turbo
it needs a manufacturer
so there is nothing as evaluate
evolution or um something that created
itself or evolved no this is baloney
have we created ourselves definitely
iraq not we can't even create look look
at this eye of mine so perfect not
because it's mine so yeah it might add
some
value to it
and i is so perfect
so precise
yet no power on earth can create a
similar eye that it's in this socket
that is protected by this the the skull
itself's structure
how many eyes are there
on earth at the moment
almost 16 million eyes
except what's in the wombs of women that
it's under the making
tell me how many eyes are there of
animals how many eyes are there of birds
how many eyes are there of fish how many
eyes are there of
insects who created all of this
oh it's it's evolution it's nature it's
uh anything but god
so with all due respect
atheists
i'm not gonna waste my time talking to
them because
if they fail to see the sun and they
brought light
then they have something wrong with
their heads
do you see a lot of the questions that
you get
more and more revolving somewhat around
this you know where they talk about some
some muslims not going to university and
having a crisis of faith
are you getting more of these types of
questions from people who are not well
grounded in the dean or some maybe who
are but then they go to university and
now the professor you know philosophy
for us or he puts on the board no god
here and then he gets struck by this and
his faith gets challenged are you seeing
this more
well with grace of allah azzawajal
i would
say that this is point zero zero zero
one of the questions that i get
those who approach me eddie
they know me they've been with me for
the past like 21 years since i started
in in the media in the social media
alhamdulillah so they know my track
record they come for
a solution that they believe would fit
the quran
they're not from a different sect or a
cult
let alone to be atheists however i do
get few questions from parents who
suffer from their children so they say
chef can you sit with my child for a
little while i said yeah sure so
alhamdulillah usually takes between five
to 15 minutes max
to talk and communicate with kids with
boys with girls and
it is so
easy to get them back into islam with
the grace of allah
you don't have to be a rocket scientist
oh what you have to do is to know your
religion to know how to speak to people
not over uh um
superficial issues rather go deep into
the happida
and this is where our mistake
is
when we think that
is only technicalities what did the
murtazila say what did the ashari say
what did the jamia say
and neglecting what
our quran and our
sunnah said once we learn it
as it is displayed in the quran
and know who allah is the almighty then
we've got it made
so now the
questions that you get
what are some of the main ones you also
do the the counseling so what would you
say are the top priority of things now
that are affecting us for this day and
generation the things that you're seeing
answering so many of these questions
that are coming to you on the forefront
uh the the counseling is different
see the counseling is usually
divided between match counseling
so this is a problem between two spouses
one of them wants a solution wants an
eye opener or both of them having
problems with one another or one wants
to divorce or one wants to get married
and usually they come to me
as
a sheikh as someone they trust in
religion alhamdulillah and due to the
age and experience i have because if i
were not on your live show i would have
shown you my high heel traces on my head
due to being married to two pre in a
previous life for more than 25 years
together so as
a man with two wives for this long or
quarter of a century
you get to know women
and you know that to know how they think
so they come to me for
an eye-opener because i'm not a
psychiatrist
i'm not a shrink i'm just there to
help them in accordance with the quran
to tell them what's right and what's
wrong
some of them come to vent i don't
take their preventing
the session is half an hour they may
speak for five minutes only
and i do the rest of speaking because
i can see exactly what
suffering from has given no you're wrong
as a man you're a wimp you're not a real
man you should have done this you should
have done that as a woman you have all
the right to stand up for yourself and
ask for divorce or do this or as a woman
you should fear allah because you'll be
cursed on the day of judgment of the
things you do
now other part of the counseling session
is
and and this like 35 to 40 percent
is about
people who have ocd
so you get people
ocd-ish
when it comes to purity
they perform wudu in half an hour
they spend an hour taking total basal
they wash the toilet like six times a
day more than they pray
why do you do this since we feel we
think we believe
doubts that overwhelm them from shaytan
then you go to the higher level or the
lower depending how you look at it where
these viswas and whispers
are about shirk about kufuru so sheikh i
was putting my uh um uh earbuds
in my ear
and i smiled
is that kufur
i said what the heck what do you mean by
kufur said yeah because i remember that
the prophet when he made wudu he used to
wipe his ears so i smiled
he said this is not related this is not
kufur this is utter stupidity you should
see a psychiatrist a muslim psychiatrist
so
i get to check with people who think
that okay did i commit kufur did i exit
the fold of islam did i do this did i do
that by opening their eyes and telling
them listen this is how shaytan messes
up with your head through two ways
either
you're inclined to partying all night
long and drinking booze and womenizing
so he doesn't care about your whispers
indeed he opens venues and sins or
you're in so meticulous about
things related to islam so keen on
pursuing what gets closer to allah so he
exaggerates things and makes you go to
extreme
a grain of sand he makes it in your head
as big as a mountain so you think
everything is making you uh
doomed and
bound to hell this is my job is to open
their eyes the rest of the questions i
get
are the usual
questions about halal food music
pre-mixing
sometimes consultation of what to do
i have a best friend who's not talking
to me i have a best friend who mocks the
dean or religion i have this i have that
and things related to transactions to
selling and buying riba um and and the
likes
uh what you mentioned uh the term uh
psychologist psychiatrist um a couple
times what is it when you see this
where is the the line where you
mentioned seeing a muslim psychologist
so what's the line there within the deen
within islam with psychology and islam
obviously psychologists study study of
human behavior and whatnot but have you
seen sometimes when there's a conflict
there you know when you have secular
psychology
and then you have the teachings of dean
do you see how is the fine what's the
what's the in your experience the fine
line there where you
have you seen some contradictions there
because some we've seen some growing
thing here
uh that people now are seeing that some
people as this is almost sometimes
they'll take the
advice from the psychologist over the
the dean
well uh unfortunately
this is happening in so many places now
psychology is a science
there's no doubt in that but
who
had ever said that every science is
infallible nobody
now if you analyze what the science
[Music]
is
upon you fees that there is it is
totally irrelevant and wrong
so a muslim psychiatrist when he
analyzes a problem he knows when this is
closer to being schizophrenia whether a
person is
bipolar or not
and such
a person being bipolar would swing
with both swings
is this
something that
justifies him doing things and then we
can say oh oh the poor thing he's
bipolar he's exempted is did he reach
the level of insanity where
when he does something he's not
accountable
like the thing that happens in the west
so many times so a murderer may
uh skip punishment because of his
psychiatric evaluation
and this is not the case in islam a
muslim psychiatrist is a person who
balances this science
with our islamic beliefs
because
unlike other religions
islam is the only religion that came up
with a law with the sharia that is valid
till the end of time
so we have a law from the quran that
governs
a relationship
man
to man our relationship meant to allah
and the rest of the world
so if someone kills someone we have to
know because insanity is a level where
we can
abstain from
uh inflicting the prescribed punishment
for
uh uh
the predetermined murder and
manslaughter
so this is why a muslim psychiatrist is
needed we have to know when to give
medication
lots of the modern psychiatrists would
just put you on prozac oh you have
depression go ahead
take uh um
medical marijuana
everybody's
going for that nowadays especially in
your country the state so i get lots of
questions sheriff i'd like to do
part you know and it's medical reason
not to get high
what is this yes this is permissible in
very very very very limited cases but
now with psychiatrists with doctors who
don't know islam would prescribe it for
everybody
so
yes a muslim psychiatrist is the right
one to strike the balance and to know
what is uh applicable what is not
sometimes spiritual healing is in in
need
instead of getting medication all what
you need is to learn who allah is
is to learn why he created you and to
trust him
a lot of our problems
are solved
if we
manage to trust allah
dealing now with uh many couples also
with your therapy sessions are you
seeing the divorce rate increasing
decreasing and what are some of the
causes if if so
the majority of the cases alhamdulillah
are decreasing when
someone intervenes someone with
knowledge not me of course but if an
elder in the family sits with them and
this
concept
is mentioned in the quran
that when there is a conflict between
the spouses send an arbitrator
from his family and from hers
so they both come and sit together and
delegate and
talk about the problem and come up with
um
solutions that may be accepted accepted
by both parties
this is best see islam does not promote
divorce
and this is why verse 34
chapter 4 in the quran allah gives a
sequence
and this sequence may not be
preferred by so many people because they
think of okay how is it possible for a
man to beat
his woman and he's not beating him with
a baseball bat
allah says
those
who are
uh disobedient and rebellious among your
wives you have to
advise them
so for a whole month or two i'm
reminding her of allah i'm telling her
this is not good for the family come on
honey this is not right you have to do
this according to the law of allah
i have no problem do you want to follow
sharia or do you want to follow your
whims and desires if the woman says i
want to follow sharia good for you
that's look what shariah says and we
follow it this is what
we
how we solve conflicts
there's a conflict between me and you
eddie you say right i say left
so
what to do we can't but one we can't
fight it off so we bring someone to
arbitrate the person who arbitrates
comes to us and say
do you want to follow sharia
or do you want to follow your whims and
desires as muslims immediately you say
sharia
there's no doubt in that
then he displays what the shariah says
and if i was wrong
i will say i adhere
[Music]
if i'm not a real muslim i would say no
let's go to the civil court
let's go to
a shaman who would uh say something in
my favor rather than yours then this
indicates that i'm not a true real
genuine muslim
in marriages the same thing happens
so if the man is the oppressor
i say to him
desires
if he says well it depends what sharia
says i said
case is closed because you don't want
islam
if both of them want islam alhamdulillah
we reach a settlement and a conclusion
that is
acceptable to both and most of these
cases alhamdulillah end up in this way
uh you mentioned a term that some might
not be familiar with you mentioned
sharia i just wanted to point out is it
true i mean i've had i guess some before
who are arabic speaking like yourself
that in the arabic bible you have sharia
mentioned over 200 times
moses peace be upon him who we love in
revere is one of the mightiest
messengers
he also brought the ten commandments
would this be considered shariah
definitely allah says
to all of these nations we have given
ishariah
and a methodology away
so yes the uh judaism has a sharia it
has the ten commandments it has laws of
its own but these laws are not
applicable to all times and this is why
all the previous religions had a time
limit
and this time limit was over
when the following religion came until
islam
when islam came it was declared on day
one that this is the final religion the
final revelation from allah azzawajal
that there's nothing else going to
uh come after it
that's why it's the perfect
reigning sharia law the reigning
religion for the past 15 centuries
the only scripture the only book anyone
any religion can come up and say listen
this is my scripture not a single letter
has been changed over the past 15
centuries and the language is spoken by
more than 400 million
uh
living
beings at the moment so it's not an
archaic language or something that we
need translators for
uh are you familiar with uh an actor
narrator he's pretty well known his name
is uh
morgan freeman
yeah he's well known
yes uh he traveled around uh many parts
of the world you know and one part uh
where he actually got a chance to listen
to the adhan to visit the masjid i want
you to go ahead and have a look at this
this is actually in egypt
and then uh give me your thoughts your
reaction to this
i've decided to return to cairo to try
and understand who god is to muslims
islam believes in the same god as jews
and christians
but i want to know if there are
differences in how they think about the
divine
historian of islam ahmed rahgab has
brought me to the al hussein
mosque
and you can just come in here just like
the catholic church so it's always open
to prayer yeah if you want to come in
here and
you can hang out with uh
yourself and allah yeah absolutely
i'm just in time to hear what muslims
believe is one of the most beautiful
sounds in the world
the call to prayer
allah
[Music]
for the faithful
the song of the muay zen
is a manifestation of god himself
so that's the end of the prayer is
by saying assalamu alaikum much like you
in you end an encounter with anybody and
it is because the prayer is essentially
a meeting with god
elections like hey you know see you
later nice talk
see you the next time
that's in egypt no so what do you what
do you think morgan freeman if we all i
mean we can end up dying tomorrow before
him we don't know when our death day
departure date is but if uh if we just
go by years he's uh closer than than
most of us right so now he's got to hear
some of the
teachings of islam if we if we have to
send the message to morgan freeman and
then maybe if he was to visit your area
of the world maybe he can come also
visit with you
and uh in his next documentary series
well first of all yani we wish and hope
for all
humans to accept islam regardless of
their position of the rank of their
fame
now uh having said that morgan freeman
i think was doing this documentary
for a purpose
and he wasn't doing it for him own self
so he has a script
and he's following the script if they
were to take him to a hindu temple he
would have said what was in the script
like what's his name this uh
i have a certain skills uh that i will
know how to get you and i don't know how
to kill you uh lithium linux
when he was in turkey yes some something
like that so he they praised that he was
so
impressed with azan and later on he was
yeah
i mean it's part of the job
so we wish that they all come to islam
we wish that they come and ask us and
debate us and ask us what what islam is
i i don't like this in your religion no
problem
i'll clarify it to you
they have so many scholars or diaries or
students of knowledge around them they
can get in touch with but they don't
because this is their lifestyle
if
you read the sunnah the prophet
sent to hercules or to the
emperor of the byzantines a message
the prophet as i've sent him a message
when this
ruler this emperor read the message said
wallahi he is on the right path and if i
were
next to him i would have taken his shoes
and washed his feet and drank the water
of that so people asked him okay
are you accepting islam said no no no i
was just testing the people
the prophet said that is islam he
did
not want to waste his empire
so
he knew that accepting islam means
losing all the wealth losing all the
power losing losing his empire
so he
decided to keep that over
that thing is done most celebrities are
like this who wants to let go of all the
wealth and fame
for
claiming that oh islam is beautiful
you have to submit your will you're not
able to do this so unfortunately but
yeah sure thing anyone who wants to come
and talk to me or let alone i wouldn't
say talk to me talk to someone who's
more knowledgeable talk to scholars talk
to someone who you may benefit from but
if they want to come and talk to this
poor slave of allah i'm always there and
just a phone call away
let's go back to this now this is
historical people go reference this
check it up heracles now so this is this
was a ruler at that time so he's exposed
to
islam he's exposed to the last and final
messenger sent to mankind prophet
muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
who often says brother to jesus moses
abraham know all the preceding
messengers he didn't come with anything
different he came with the same message
worship the one and only creator that
heavens in earth the creator not his
creation
and he's exposed to it so he's saying
you know he's testing the waters now and
he sees that this is the truth he said
what'd he say he said if i was with him
i'd wash his feet
and drink the water
hold on hold on this is really deep for
people who admire historical figures
like alexander the great and you know uh
they watch many of these movies uh
braveheart and many of these people out
there you know some are even fictional
but now heracl this is a real this is
not someone from the movies
no no the guy
gathered all of his priests and monks
and head of church
and ordered his guards to lock the door
and he recited to them the stories and
he recited to them some of the verses
on uh isa peace be upon him jesus christ
and his mother
and his
miraculous birth
and the priests and monks started crying
until their beards were were wet
christians these are christians crying
now because they're hearing the quran
they are hearing the quran
and miraculous heracles is setting up
this meeting now
now so
after that after he saw them being so
emotionally moved
by the truth of the quran he said to
them so what do you think should we
follow him
so he just
was testing the water in a in a positive
way
they
immediately overturned
because
their love of power
and love of wealth kicked in
she said and they started rebelling
against him no we will not do this and
so much chaos and the shouting and
disturbance
and he knew this this is why he locked
the door from the inside so he said no
no no no calm down calm down or just
testing your iman if you're real
believers or not
and everything went back to normal
so when this reached the prophet alaihi
salatu salam
he said in
arabic oh this wretched person he
was
favoring his wealth and power over islam
that's why he would not give it up
wow
this was unlike
unlike the reaction of the persian
leader
who torn the letter of the prophet
and rejected even to reply to him
because
hercules gave
the the messenger who came a gift
and a concubine and some jewelry
back to the protestant as a form of
honoring respect he gave he showed some
respect yeah
he said i want people to imagine this he
said if i was with him i would wash his
feet and drink that water
yes out of because
all christians know
of the one that prophet
isa prophet jesus peace be upon him gave
the glad tidings of his coming
and
they knew that there was someone coming
to fix the world and jesus christ said
this in the bible and he said that he'll
come after me he will speak not from his
own self but he would speak from uh um
yeah i'm not a biblical historian so i
i'm not zakir night either so you go
ahead and check it out can you get them
on the phone real quick
i wish i wish i seriously i can't but
not at the moment
so
um
you find
evidences that are beyond doubt
that they knew there was some someone
coming and we know who this someone is
and we can see it through his track
record
just open your eyes what do people hate
about islam there are those who have
in it
in uh enmity against islam
like some european countries without
naming them
even
when the european council came yesterday
with an ad
showing a woman without hijab half
picture and a woman with hijab
half picture
to show the integrity the
um uh how
uh cultures blend
in europe because muslims are a great
portion of of uh the population in
europe it's an ad a woman with no hijab
and a woman with hijab they blend them
in so half of the girl is without and
half is with what happened this european
country came up front and said no this
is totally unacceptable we object
because this denies the christian and
the jewish heritage of europe
they have
hatred to hijab
anything that respects women they have a
problem with if a woman
comes out with a bikini or wearing a
thumb good for you that's the thing
that's what we like to see
they have no
fear no
bashfulness no shyness
they hate islam full stop
so you with a beard cut it
you wear hijab take it off
when corona came
people started wearing the mask
they they were shocked what can we do
they're wearing nikab legally
they couldn't do anything about it but
when it's out of your conviction out of
your belief out of your religion no we
have a problem
so these are great examples for morgan
freeman or whoever else doesn't matter
the message is open for every everyone
uh now
you mentioned the persian king you
struck an example a contrast here when
he and this also now look if someone
wants to see if the
quran is from the creator of the heavens
and earth they want to take a scientific
analytical approach they will see that
this is indeed from the crate the proof
is overwhelming but then you see these
small details that are there that are
just you know mind-blowing like
this example that you were going to give
with the persian king there was a
prediction in there you can say
something that was going to happen and
can you go ahead and talk about this
when those messengers came and then the
prophet muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him what did he predict or say
something that's going to happen in the
future that they didn't even know until
like what a month's journey or several
weeks journey
when the messengers came
and they told the prophet and he told
the prophet it was one messenger and he
told the prophet that this is what
the persian
emperor did he torn
your letter
unlike what happened with the christians
who honored it and sent with the gift
what was in the letter what
what was the letter about
for people that i don't know what's in
the letter
the letter was simply stating that peace
be upon those who follow the guidance of
allah
come to islam and you will be rewarded
for yourself and for all those who
follow
you
and if you do not accept islam the
message of allah which is to believe in
monetism which to believe that the
prophet muhammad is the messenger of
allah
then you shall be punished for your sins
and the sins of those who follow you so
it's a call to islam it's an invitation
with sent with an and a messenger
so he
out of arrogance
out of pride
he
tore it up
and
sent the messenger back
when the messenger came back to the
prophet saw and told him
the prophet said two words
he said may allah
tear
his kingdom
and
on that particular day
which the muslims came to know a month
or so later when the news came on that
particular night
this emperor
was killed
and he had no male offspring so his
daughter
took his position in leading the country
which led it to go downhill and we all
know how they were conquered by the
muslims
wow subhanallah so you have this
what is historically documented you have
heracles you have him like you
are bringing to our attention that he
put all the christians together they got
to hear some of the quran they're crying
weeping
uh they recognize this as the truth
but they didn't accept because their
power like now what are you gonna do
you're gonna just live for prestige
power you're gonna live for just the
things of this world are you gonna
accept the truth but with the truth
there come sometimes consequences right
people rebelling like they were going to
do against him uh but then you have
other examples
you know uh you gave this example the
persian but then there was also others
christians who also accepted like the
christian king of abyssinia
so this is another example of a
christian can you talk about who now
he
also was someone who was just who was
fair someone who later did he accept
islam
well this was way way back in the
beginning in the early times of islam
the letters to the najaf to the uh
to the persian emperor to the emperor of
bahrain which is the eastern part of of
saudi arabia uh the emperor of
the byzantines the king of coptics of
egypt and to the abyssinian ruler these
were on the ninth year of hijrah
which is
uh
22 years
after the revelation started
that was about two years before the
death of the prophet islam
if i'm not mistaken
so it's almost
when people came to accept islam etc
this is when it was sent
and it might have been
let me recollect no no i was wrong i was
wrong sorry i apologize um
you don't have to edit this but this
just to show how poor i am and how
mistakes i make this was way back
because when it came to the abyssinian
emperor
abu sufyan
was at the time of the truce
between the muslims and the this the
mushrikeen and this was before the
conquest of mecca so this was before
between year six and year eight of
hijrah
this is when it it took place now the
abyssinian king you're talking about his
name was
she
he was christian
at the time he was christian but this
incident took place
12 13 years ago
meaning that when the muslims were
prosecuted in mecca before they migrated
to medina
they were so
finding it difficult to live
to the extent that the prophet hassan
told them listen allah has made way out
for you you may migrate to abyssinia
which means that you have to get on
boats cross the red sea go to a foreign
land with a different language and
nowadays if you're a uh
frequently flyer
and you have
access to different airlines and hotels
no problem you can just come
send me an invitation to kuala lumpur
and i'll come within eight to ten hours
that time it was
like the difference between life and
death
for for bedouins to go on ships and
cross the sea
not knowing how to swim to a foreign
land whoa
so
they went there now the thing is that
the prophet told them
go there because there is a king
people would not be oppressed under his
reign
and that is one mind-blowing fact
because
for
a man who was illiterate who did not
read
and they didn't have any fox news or cnn
at the time
yet he knew
who the rulers of countries around him
and how they dealt with their people
this shows you that the amount of
knowledge the prophet had i suspected
about what was going on
so he said to them go to him
so they went
and they asked permission to live in his
country
and the the najashi the abyssinian king
allowed them to
after some time
the idol worshipers of quraysh of
the enemies of islam
did not like this so they sent two men
to
try to persuade the king to send them
back
these men one of them was
pleased with him who was a kafir at the
time
they went with lots of gifts
so they gave all the close ones to the
king
particular gifts watches jewelries
golden pens money
so they bought the court of the king
and then they went to the king
and said to him we have a problem with
our
locals who came to you their renegades
and they
say bad things about our gods and idols
so we would like you to send them back
with us
we will deal with them
all those around the king says yeah yeah
they know their people
send them back with them we don't need
strangers and definitely we're not going
to build a wall
like trump's
so send them back
so he said no they came and chose my
hospitality and country
how can i return them back i would not
do this yes
so following day
went to the king and said
ask them what they say about jesus
because they say something that is
extremely wild and inappropriate
being a christian he said okay i have to
hear what he
they say about him
so he gathered them
their spokesperson was
of course the brother of ali
so he was the spokesman who came in
and gave his speech
and he said i will read you verses from
al-quran
and he read the verses from the quran
portraying
the miraculous birth of
jesus christ and what had happened with
his mother
by the time he ended
reciting the quran
tears was filling up the face of najashi
and
even
his monks and priests
and he said to them
is nothing more than what they have
recited
jesus is when yeah
jesus christ this is when the monks and
priests started to
become angry
because it says that jesus
had no father
and there was no male intervention
rather it was the archangel gibril who
planted
his soul
in the womb of mother mary
they did not like this
and
the abyssinian cave was unlike the
hercules he
and he told them do whatever you want
you are free to worship
allah wow
so this is a great you know because a
lot of times people they get kind of a
superficial
understanding about islam morgan freeman
now these are the kind of stories i mean
you have so much
uh isn't there a verse in the quran the
verbatim word of god almighty that allah
is talking about that when there is
amongst them those who when they hear
the truth you know they shed tears so
now you have an example of the
christians during the time of miraculous
and now another abyssinian king here
who later accepted islam you have them
shedding tears they're hearing the truth
and now morgan freeman or anybody else
can be liam neeson again it's
interesting about liam neeson that there
was uh when he came back
because you mentioned this he was uh in
the first
part of his stay in turkey he was
annoyed with that and then you know how
the story goes is an older story but
then he started he said it was something
like it was penetrating his soul and
there was even talk you'd watch him on
some of these talk shows talking about
you know he was like kind of pumped up
but then he got hit with the backlash
from community and that's now your test
are you going to submit to what he and
she says you know the community or
stardom or are you going to actually go
down that path and accept the truth so
these are great stories for morgan
freeman and others to really take a deep
dive and look into islam so what would
you say to someone like morgan freeman
uh someone who now they think that just
this is just another religion there's
some good in there just like other
religions and whatnot
but you have clear passages in the quran
where god almighty i mean if you look at
this quran this book there's no way that
it can come from anyone else there's not
contradiction upon contradiction you
know there's not different versions of
the quran
it's not you know
a court a collection of books from
anonymous authors this is from the
creator who created you me and the whole
universe and everything in it and he's
saying that whoever chooses a way of
life other than complete and total
submission to him and him alone to the
creator of the universe never will that
way of life be accepted so what would
you if you had to sit down now he's
traveling morgan freeman he comes to
your part of the world jeddah he's doing
his documentary and now you're talking
with them what what would you
what are the kind of things how would
you invite him to this beautiful way of
life of islam
usually i
follow a very easy
way of
thinking very simple not a rocket
scientist as if rocket science is the
best and no i'm not someone who's uh
sophisticated i'm an easy going person
i'm easy like friday morning so um i
wouldn't go into complicated stuff
philosophical stuff i don't know these
stuff alhamdulillah i know black and
white i'm a logical person so i would
say to him listen
you believe in the existence of one
creator
most likely he said definitely
okay this
one creator would it be wise to create
all this perfection
in this life in this world and leave
them astray without showing them what is
right and what's wrong
you wouldn't expect
a apple to produce a device
so magnificent so
sleek so nice and not tell people
whether it's a phone or a tv
set or a microwave
they would have to show them how it
works
operation manual etc so allah azzawajal
definitely would show us how to worship
him what to do and what is expected from
us it's logical
but all religions do this okay excellent
number one
are all religions
right at the side of allah
said uh maybe
no no it can be
if they are all right they mean that
they all share the same values do they
share the same same values no no no this
religion goes right this religion goes
left this religion does not even exist
on earth so definitely the truth
beside allah is one
so which one which religion this is the
acid test you have to do to each
religion come to christianity scrutinize
it look into it deeply to see if it is
the accepted religion
to god at the moment
do you have an original scripture of the
new testament of the injil
no we have a translation of a
translation of a translation you have
the
original manuscript no does anybody know
the original manuscript and how no do
you have one virgin no we have hundreds
the catholics have the douay virgin the
protestants
have the king james version we have the
new standard virgin we have the red dot
uh virgin or letter
thousands of copies
okay go to other religions hindus
buddhism
do they
share the perfection
the authenticity
the
sustainability of all religions
uh uh like islam or not
you will come to the conclusion that
okay
with all religions
ratings i will rate islam to have the
highest eighty percent
let's assume eighty percent not a
hundred percent is there anything close
to it no the second close is like thirty
or forty five
okay
so why aren't you accepting islam oh
because it's eighty if it's 80
the 80 which is right and correct and
authentic should overwhelm the 20 that
have doubtful in your head
though i guarantee you that the future
and the science will prove the other 20
that you're not
being able to buy
it's a very
easy
way of communicating
but people who are rigid people who say
no no no i believe that jesus freed my
life that jesus cured my parents
paralysis
that jesus did this
jesus came to me
like one american
president said
jesus came to him god came to him and
told him to invade other countries and
they said oops sorry i did it again it
was it was a mistake there were no
weapons of mass destruction okay sorry
for the million kills
tough luck next time inshallah
subhanallah so uh yeah these are a lot a
lot of things you know just uh simple
facts there's not some hocus-pocus stuff
that people throw at you and you got to
put your like intelligence on hold uh
when you were mentioning we were
mentioning all these christians
uh and then scholars you know people of
intellect you had so many people who
were enemies opponents
of the truth but later they became
lovers of the truth they accepted the
truth i mean this is you know when
people study the life
you know from the authentic sources when
they study the life
you know the history of prophet muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him not
through the opponents of islam you have
another christian you have another
scholar
uh who also if you can just touch upon
this
this was somebody now who was a scholar
of that time who know who knew all the
other you know what they had of the
remnants of the truth of you know of the
of the torah what they had of you know
the teachings of jesus at that time
whatever he had he studied it and then
when he saw prophet muhammad what did he
recognize him as an imposter or as
indeed that anticipated prophet who was
supposed to be sent the last and final
seal of the prophets
he immediately accepted him and he said
to him
but if i wear
a young when your people would kick you
out prophet said everyone came
with the same religion
no one
came with the same religion that you
came up with except he would face enmity
of his people but
eddie with all due respect when you
bring all these stories
if i were in their shoes i would say
that okay this is history
it might be right it might be wrong
i could find uh maybe one in a million
who was a muslim devout muslim who
rejected islam
so does this
no
it's not the way the way is that allah
gave you
intellect allah gave you a brain to
think of and to analyze things off you
have to do your due diligence
come and sit
and
think
is this the system that manages the
whole world without problems or conflict
is this the law that ensures justice to
all regardless of color and he is a man
of color
how did the muslims deal with blacks
who were among the most
uh prominent of the companions of the
prophet
they were black
and the prophet stated this 15 centuries
ago there is no privilege
for a white over a black
[Music]
we have a few more minutes shake uh we
lost you there are you there can you
hear us can you hear me yeah yeah i can
hear you how powerful is this just
leaving him morgan freeman liam neeson
whoever is out there you know from the
average uh persian blue-collar worker
who's tuning in
and they like what they have what we
were talking about you know how powerful
this is
yeah can you hear me
hello
we lost you there a little bit i see
we i okay i hear you now okay do you
hear me good good
yeah yeah yeah
so what i was saying was how powerful
yet it's so simple
talking about you know this pure
monotheism and directing people because
sometimes when you ask someone i've had
experience asking you know the person
who's in his uh late 70s 80s have you
ever thought about the purpose of life
have you ever asked the creator life for
guidance
so i've interviewed so many people over
the years and when they did this simple
yet profound thing of asking the creator
for guidance alone because
the devil shaitan makes things confusing
oh so many religions they're all the
same just that and the other and so it
makes it so complicated but then you
know how powerful is this to leave
morgan freeman or just the average
layman to now ask ask for the guidance
from the one who created you
whoever asks allah azzawajal
wholeheartedly allah will guide him
i guarantee you this
so i don't ask people to come to islam
i just ask them to ask allah almighty to
guide their heart to the straight path
if they're sincere in that
they will be guided imagine what was
the dua
the supplication that our prophet allah
used to open his night prayer
and night prayer is something that
people offer
as
a voluntary act it's not part of the
five pillars of islam it's something
that is a bit higher it's a bonus so
people wake up at 3 a.m
an hour or two before
the break of dawn when everybody's
asleep nobody's awake
so
the prophet used to wake up
and his supplication would
the three greatest angels of allah
after you praise allah with all of these
beautiful praises you ask so you say
guide me
to what
righteousness and truth
people have disagreed upon
what does that show you it shows you
that even the prophet of allah
is begging allah all the almighty every
single night to guide him
to whatever truth people have differed
upon
because if allah doesn't guide you
you're lost you're astray
and the moment you think of yourself
that oh i'm strong i'm king i'm the uh
the champion i'm the owner of everything
look at all the celebrities the poor
things
50 years ago who were
the
first page
articles all the time
always on the first page their pictures
their events they're
they were so beautiful so handsome so
strong
where is all of that
down the drain
50 years later another one bites the
dust then what is going on
don't you think that there is a life
after death
shouldn't you at least know
what's the means of transportation the
accommodation what's awaiting me is it a
suite a royal suite or is it a room in a
dungeon
i have to figure it out now
the problem the biggest problem is that
such people not only celebrities the
vast majority of the population
they are enslaved to their desires
so when you come to one and say okay
come to islam
where i cannot
jeopardize my red wine of 1982 that was
a good year
with a big piece of
pork chops
i i can't i can't play with that and
your religion prohibits it
is this all what life is about you're
willing but if your cardiologists say
you have high level of cholesterol you
have to stop this or you're going to die
next week
you got to stop it then you're on it
yeah
you have a problem okay think about what
awaits you and look for
the right way out
whether it's islam or any other religion
i'm fine with that
but
i i i bet you halal betting from one
side not from yourself that if you
ask allah for guidance you will be
guided
and this is what the creator is saying
all my slaves are misguided unless i
guide them so ask me of my guidance
is not the creator this is hadith
very authentic
yes subhanallah so leave us with
something shay what else what do you
leave us with for again morgan freeman
anybody out there the average muslim
what advice do you leave us before we
conclude
if i conclude it by anything they will
say oh the sheikh is envious because he
was not awarded any part in our movies
if you give me trillions of dollars i
would not ever think of participating in
this life
i've done that i've been there
alhamdulillah and i know
everything about this life that allah
has
blessed me not to be in
i would urge you
it's not your wealth that we're after
it's not your
uh blue eyes or your mansions or your
faith
it's for your own
good
look
into what may save you on the day of
judgment
don't put blind folders
so that you don't see don't be like a
race horse that has these folders on the
side of his head so that he doesn't look
right and left and only moves forward
because this is not how it is seek allah
for guidance
and
open your mind to the truth
and the truth shall guide you with the
grace of allah
for the person just one more question
who's never heard this term allah now
that they think allah there's a moon god
what are you talking about allah you
know i call on god god
okay i have a series on my youtube
channel
which is called the beautiful names of
allah
and i explained 102 names authentic
names of allah the almighty that he
called himself in and the greatest name
of all is allah
which all other names direct to
so when you say who is allah you don't
say the most beneficial the most
merciful no when someone asks what is
the most beneficial the most merciful
you say allah
what is the almighty you say allah what
is
the generous you say allah all names
relate to allah
who is allah
he is the creator of the heavens and the
earth he is the creator of the universe
there was allah and nothing was with him
imagine there was a point of time though
time
is a creation of allah
allah was there and nothing was with him
allah is the creator of this universe
and the whole universe
is
nothing compared to allah except when
you compare a ring to tossed in a desert
so allah is the name
of the only
worthy of being
they call him god
they call him
[Applause]
other names but this is the name of
allah that he accepted for himself
mentioned in other scriptures
those who study but this is the name
that he acknowledged himself to be
called in islam
don't uh arabic speaking jews and
christians also call upon god by the
name allah correct they do and even
before islam they used to have names
like abdullah so the father of the
prophet salam
who was not a muslim his name was
abdullah
the servant of allah so this is the god
that jesus he called upon by allah and
this is the god that people jesus called
people to worship not himself but they
this is the one that jesus worshiped
also correct correct
thank you thank you for being with us
again uh here on the dean's show
inshallah we don't let too many years go
by again before we uh have another nice
session like this inshallah
for having an apologize for the internet
connection but you guys are like five
six thousand miles away you should come
closer to saudi inshallah thank you may
allah bless you